in the middle of every humanitarian
crisis there are always human faces and
these are the children women and men
stuck in a deadly standoff on the poland
belarus border
thousands are now in makeshift camps
along the razor wire humanitarian groups
say they're lacking food and medicine
social media footage from recent days
shows several hundred refugees and
migrants escorted by bella russian
security heading towards poland the
large numbers have escalated a crisis
that's been boiling for many weeks
many if they can get into the eu don't
want to stay in poland where they know
they're not welcome
no go to poland we all going to germany
germany is live no poland for months
thousands have been entering the block
through belarus at first fire lithuania
and latvia now mainly through poland the
eu accuses belarussian leader alexander
lukashenko of orchestrating waves of
migrants and refugees in retaliation for
sanctions imposed on his government for
violent crackdowns on the opposition
on monday poland said it had withstood
attempts by migrants to force their way
across the border authorities have
accused belarus of trying to spark a
major confrontation and immobilizing
soldiers and closed a border crossing
prime minister matteos morovici has been
visiting troops
who would think two three months ago
that we would be dealing with actions
that are characterized by the use of
human shields lukashenko's regime uses
civilians as weapons in a hybrid war
what we can see today are new methods
and you are a bastion against them
but poland's authorities have been
accused of illegal behavior too forcibly
transporting people they've caught back
across the border rather than offering
humanitarian assistance and the chance
to apply for protection
there's been little coordinated action
from the eu germany is urging member
states to do more
russia a close ally and adviser to
belarus says the crisis is a result of
the west's policies in the middle east
and urges it to help belarus
the root of the problem is the policy
carried out by western countries
including nato and eu member states
regarding the middle east and north
africa over years as they were trying to
impose a western style better life
several people along the border have
already died from exposure there could
be many more to come rory challenge al
jazeera
well dominic kane is following the story
from berlin dominic what have the eu
commission had to say about this
lots of words coming from the european
union from several different officials
not the least of them from the president
of the european commission ursula fond
de la and she says that what's happening
on that border that we saw we're hearing
rory report about there
basically the
instrumentalization of refugees says
president fond airline in other words
that she is accusing the belarusian
government of using these refugees these
migrants as an instrument of foreign
policy president van der lion wants to
have much more sanctions imposed in
belarus and that's the view that other
politicians in other parts of the eu
seem to be endorsing too we know that
here the german government the interior
minister has has effectively endorsed
the polish government's
approach vis-a-vis the uh the safety the
security of the border with belarus the
idea of militarization of the of that
zone of a fence being put there we know
also that the lithuanian government has
said that it is putting everything in
place in order to have and to enact a
state of emergency along its border with
belarus remember that lithuania and
poland have the longest longest borders
with belarus those are the frontiers
which are now the front line of this
hybrid war that we were hearing the
polish government representative refer
to there so from the european
perspective from the eu perspective at
least you have solidarity being
expressed in brussels and in other
member states for what the polish
government is doing the other thing to
bear in mind is that the other member
states well they are aware of the fact
that many of these migrants and refugees
seek to go through poland to germany for
example we know that in the course of
the last five weeks or so on average
more than a thousand people have managed
to get from belarus through poland into
germany now there's no suggestion that
these numbers have any kind of relation
to the numbers who came to germany in
2015 at the height of the refugee crisis
involving syrian refugees but certainly
the images of these people on that
yellow russian border with poland have
stirred people's memories and they are
the subject of political debate right
now
dominic kane there live for us there in
berlin thank you dominic